en France
9,2% des personnes de 75 ans ou plus
vivent en EHPAD mais certains ont trouvé
une alternative la maison partagée vivre
en colocation avec d'autres personnes
âgées c'est ce que propose l'équipe de
social et solidaire et solidaire cette
famille l'une de ces maisons est
implantée à Salbris dans le Loir-et-Cher
là-bas 8 seniors qui peuvent qui ne
peuvent plus vivre seuls cohabitent au
quotidien et des nuits des jours par des
assistantes de vie Hélène chapelet les a
rencontrés
vu de l'extérieur rien ne semble
distinguer cette habitation d'une autre
pourtant c'est ici que vivent
actuellement quatre colocataires en
perte d'autonomie cet après-midi là pour
Louise 78 ans c'est détente et vernies
dans le salon partagé elle dispose
également d'une grande chambre à l'étage
qu'elle a pu aménager avec les meubles
de son ancienne maison
laceptuagénaire est arrivée début mars
en Sologne car elle ne pouvait plus
rester dans son pavillon de Narbonne et
la colocation lui convient parfaitement
avant chez moi j'étais je pouvais tomber
et puis pas forcément avec quelqu'un qui
puisse venir me secourir alors que là là
j'ai pas de souci de ce côté là quoi
j'en ai eu beaucoup de demeures en
France quand même puis à l'étranger mais
là je sais que c'est celle-ci c'est la
dernière demeure
la maison dispose de neuf chambres 8
sont réservés aux résidents la dernière
sert aux assistantes de vie qui se
relaient nuitées jour au sein de la
colocation le concept c'est de retrouver
une structure à taille humaine qui
respecte le rythme et les envies de
chacun ici par exemple il n'y a pas
d'heure pour le petit déjeuner on n'est
pas obligé de faire ça en temps et en
heure on prend le temps avec chacun on
apprend tout ça à se connaître
puis on est tous libre quoi on recrée du
coup un esprit avec une maison une
famille on partage des moments de vie
ensemble il y a du lien social qui se
crée et tout ça a une échelle en fait
humaine où on prend le temps et oui
encore une fois ils vivent à leur rythme
et ça c'est très important
une liberté qui a un prix compter 2600
euros par mois avant les aides cette
nouvelle façon d'aborder la perte
d'autonomie semble malgré tout faire des
émules l'entreprise sociale et solidaire
cette famille dispose aujourd'hui de 25
colocations seniors dans tout l'hexagone